but you're a classical liberal in that
sense because even though we disagree
you can sit down express your point of
view and some people on the left view
that in and of itself as adding fuel to
the fire yeah and I would argue adding
fuel to the fire is simply trying to
eliminate voices from the conversation
by the way whether it's being completely
polarizing and just being like you suck
right yeah
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
for this holiday installment of change
my mind where we rationalize our
positions on seemingly controversial
topics now today's subject is an oldie
but I would argue a goodie in there are
only two genders now I should note I
first covered this topic on changed my
mind all the way back in 2017 but the
discussion around gender in the United
States and globally certainly has
undergone a major transition no pun kind
of intended we went from the argument
back then of gender being socially
constructed and existing outside of a
binary to now arguing that there are
Limitless genders in biological terms
for sex being used interchangeably with
those of gender she is now the first
female and openly transgender four-star
officer with the U.S Public Health
Service commissioned Corps a transgender
female inmate has been moved to a Men's
prison after impregnating two of the
biological female inmates after studying
Leah Thomas's times from male to female
he says statistically she is an outline
so why the DraStic change in record time
and how exactly did the students at
Texas Women's University rationalize it
well meet Gabriella who may just have
provided my favorite conversation in all
have changed my mind history see if you
can find out why Stephen nice to meet
you my name is Gabriella
oh thank you very much you know what
that's actually an incredible compliment
and I'll tell you what because I didn't
realize until very recently that
everyone's feet didn't hurt their whole
life extra extra wide feet and then I
finally found a company that said oh
yeah you just have wide feet you need to
buy wide shoes and these are the only
shoes that I have now because they're
the ones I can find so I'm glad that
they're okay so Gabriella thank you for
taking the time sitting down
sorry a little bit of dry mouth here
been talking for a while I don't know
how familiar you are if at all with the
kind of change my mind concept but um
yeah I I've seen some new videos okay so
it's an opportunity to sit down and
hopefully rationalize our positions on
seemingly controversial topics of course
this is one that to me is interesting
because I'm revisiting it I did it years
ago and back then flies around back then
uh it's interesting some of the
arguments that were presented because
we've sort of blown past them today the
idea that sex and gender are different
separate well we kind of don't subscribe
to that anymore today uh everyone back
then when I would say hey I'm concerned
about us going on the path here and
children transitioning we would say
that's absurd that's a logical fallacy
I'm sorry we're hearing aids oh I
apologize do you mind moving in and I'll
move into you I just didn't you know I
didn't want to yeah as long as you're
okay with it I'll make sure to speak
into it I didn't want to get up in your
personal space but uh for example I used
to discuss concerns bring up concerns of
children transitioning back then they
would say well that's absurd that's a
logical fallacy and of course here we
are where it's law in several States so
that's the reason I thought it would be
interesting to revisit it considering
how we've accelerated at light speed and
I still maintain that there our two
genders and if you disagree with me I'd
be uh more than happy to hear your point
of view and you can try and change my
mind
so so you and what is your stance on
this again that there are only that
there are two genders okay
I personally disagree and I know many
people
of course do agree with this and
again I very much disagree because I
view sex and gender as two things and
typically whenever you hear about
biological sex typically it's male or
female
of course you have people who are
intersex and stuff like that and I do
view gender and Sexes two different
things and I definitely do
view gender as a spectrum can I ask you
a question yes sir um on what do you
base that why do you believe that the
gender is different from sex yeah where
did where did you start believing the
definition of sex is that it is
biological and so that means chromosomes
hormones primary secondary sexual
characters yeah sure and
gender is very much a I don't want to
say psychological thing
um because that's not really correct but
uh it's gender I know what you mean yes
it's very much an identity that's why
typically the term gender and gender
identity are grouped together sure and
so that's how I personally see that so
what's interesting to me actually sir
Lena
um what's interesting to me is
what you're saying is actually what the
kinds of arguments that were presented
to me years ago right the gender and sex
are different but that's not what's even
being taught today so for example you
have you know this Administration Joe
Biden referring to Rachel Levine not as
our first woman four-star Admiral but
first female and now when you look on
government forms if you're transgender
you will check the female box depending
on the form so we are using them
fundamentally interchangeably and I
would say the reason for that is because
it was only up until very recently that
sex and gender were used interchangeably
the idea that they are separate is a
very modern Theory I would argue it's
not rooted in reality it started with
postmodern feminism start with French
existentialism and then through
postmodern feminism
um and now we end up at the point where
no one can agree on how many genders
there are or what we should do with
children who are transgender because
we've decided to tear down an
institution but have replaced it with
nothing
okay so um
okay
sorry I'm trying to it's very hard
please let me know if you don't hear you
need me to repeat myself I understand
yes sir would you mind yeah I was just
saying that um yes
okay I just don't know if it's gonna
interfere with the microphone so let me
know if you need to repeat as long as um
it doesn't touch my hearing aids because
if it does it'll be very loud microphone
oh no and I appreciate you understanding
I need to get close to not being
uncomfortable and I apologize for my
breath because I've been talking for
three hours so it's probably right it
probably smells like a turtle cage
um no what I was saying is the idea that
gender and sex are separate is very new
and it's not used consistently anymore
because you now have men and women
checking for example transgender male to
females uh checking female boxes not
woman boxes on government forms you have
the former president of the United
States Joe Biden president of the United
States
um referring to Rachel Levine as the
first female four-star admirable right
Secretary of Health they're using
they're using biological terms and the
reason for that is that they've always
been interchangeable until very recently
that's a very modern change and I would
argue that that's why they're not even
able to be consistent with that so I
don't understand the basis for someone
saying that gender is separate from sex
if it's not even agreed upon by the left
and transgender activists today
so um
you say that it wasn't until very
recently I don't know how recent you're
talking sure yes would you like I can
answer um so it actually and I would
encourage you if you do you can go
research this because if I provide
people my resources they think I'm just
lying but I make them publicly available
started with there was a lady named uh
there was someone named Simone de
Beauvoir 1949 was the first person to
say that sex is biological and gender is
societally constructed right this was
the first time that idea was floated yes
but it still existed within the binary
that women could identify as men but men
could identify as women but not this
idea that there were other genders it
was still two but that it was largely
societal his reader it was reiterated by
a few other people then um you may have
learned this in in college uh the John
money twins study did you learn that
whether you raised one as a girl one as
a boy
so yeah that was taught I believe it's
still taught in school I don't know if
you know but uh both of those boys died
one committed suicide I believe the
other from a drug overdose because he
sexually molested them and the reason
that's important is because as you know
that was taught on college campus if you
raise a twin as a boy and a twin as a
girl it was proof that it was societally
constructed but it actually had lethal
ramifications both of them had all kinds
of mental health disorders and ended up
offing themselves which is a tragedy but
it's still even with John money existed
within the binary only until Judith
Butler in the 80s and 90s did they say
gender societally constructed and by the
way there are more than two genders and
it was not created by as not a theory
that was floated from scientists from
doctors it was floated from
existentialists and feminists it's not
rooted in reality and before that gender
was really a grammatical term you know
from the romance languages like I speak
I'm French is my first language or you
know any of the languages based in Latin
right all nouns are gendered so it's a
very new Theory it's not like it's
something that's been agreed upon for a
long time and now we've come full circle
where we're using them interchangeably
again because we're calling transgender
men to women females
that's a sex term not a gender term but
those are the terms we use male to
female right typically a man woman
male female are used interchangeably
however I still do believe that they are
both very different because you say that
it's not used a lot today
I'm a pre-nursing student so we are very
much taught that yes inherently they are
different I've learned that in my
anatomy classes I've worked which it's
not touched on a lot because you very
much do biological sure um well you
would have to yes in Psychology it is
very much still taught that there are
two very different things
um as for can I ask you a question yes
sir you said you're in a nursing are you
studying pre-nursing so
now this matters right because for
example if someone fills out on the
government form right now they'll fill
out their sex and say they're a
biological male but they fill out female
uh or when they're admitted to the
hospital right often it's a biological
term but if they identify that way they
will often fill out or legally they can
fill out how they identify yes very
different metrics right as a nurse as a
doctor you need to know what you're
dealing with absolutely
yes like yes
you
said
um on documents now you can legally do
the gender that you identify with which
amazing great
um step forward for that but those
people do have to make sure that they're
like hey biologically this is what I was
assigned to at Birth and you treat them
using those metrics however that doesn't
mean that you don't treat them with
respect or treat them any less than how
they identify in some instances it's
illegal to ask the follow-up question
right it's it's discrimination against a
follow-up question in other words if
someone comes in who's biologically a
male but identifies as female if you
follow up and say well were you born a
male you're actually not allowed to ask
that question depending where you are in
certain countries that's actually
considered discrimination because they
identify well even in certain areas
there have been lawsuits in the United
States that are right now going up to
the Supreme Court
um and I think that matters for example
we've had we now hear men can get
pregnant you know as a nursing student
it's not true men cannot get pregnant
again it's very different because if you
view men only from a biological
standpoint and not just how they
identify then sure
biologically males cannot be but if you
identify as a male but you have female
reproductive organs then yes you can't
get pregnant but if they go into your
hospital
let's say let's say you're a nurse they
go into your hospital right and they
identify as a woman even though they're
a man and they take a pregnancy test if
a woman tests positive that could mean
she's pregnant the man test positive
largely means he has testicular cancer
yes right but
they don't tell you that they were born
a male or a female this is something
that we are facing in our medical
establishments right now that's why
Johns Hopkins said we won't perform the
sexual reassignment surgery you just saw
this from the NHS in the UK that they
have a problem with it they've removed
language from their website because
they're finding that there are serious
health consequences
um that come along with this and I would
say I understand I think I think I
understand where you're coming from I
think you're you're an empathetic person
um and I would say this I am coming from
a place event I don't hate anyone who's
transgender
I do see an astronomical suicide rate
both pre and post-op absolutely
um and I see that as an issue that is
not solved through transition however I
don't
it is a transgender issue because in uh
transgender youth are four times more
likely to commit suicide than the
cisgender youth and um
and that's a very big problem and
um
no that's okay I know and um hey guys
sorry
she she has hearing aids she has hearing
aids and it kind of sets them off could
you just
that's why I have to lean in it it
causes them to buzz okay is that okay
yeah I'm sorry I have a relative as a
here and I know it can just be painful
I'm sorry no it's fine I don't mind it's
just I am all over the place no I
understand so as a um
okay
okay
um yeah sorry I just wasn't expecting to
be experienced I know that that's
because you're an adult yeah I was not
expecting to be like oh she wears
hearing aids so I didn't know that we
were still doing that in the 21st
century was it because you said it was
hurting with the hearing aids I'm sorry
you're upset today no no I don't mean
you I just mean like other people being
like Oh well she was hearing aids I'm
just like I do no I was just asking to
stop yelling yeah I know I'm just
listening to what they're saying because
I can't give up with me oh you can hear
them yeah is that one of those where you
can hear further away but up close is
distorted
um it's just uh understanding so like
your voice is a little bit lower and I
have a hard time understanding lower
voices oh okay so yes sir um I can make
it higher when I get very worked up it
goes up high like this if it helps but I
try and keep it calm so yes I completely
understand I think this should just be a
very calm conversation
um yes historically transgender youth
especially um in sentences performed by
uh things such as like the Trevor
Project it's seen that um transgender
youth are four times more likely to
commit suicide than their cisgender
counterparts
um and that goes even higher with people
of color especially
um Native American slash indigenous
people and while that is there I don't
think that is a they're committing
suicide because I may be 100
misinterpreting what you were saying how
how you meant that whenever you said it
but it came off as though you meant that
in a way of like they're committing
suicide because they're transitioning
yeah well in the sense of like they're
almost being forced to transition no no
this is whatever this that's not let me
clarify what I meant okay because I've
said I've sit down with a lot of people
today and the argument is consistently
well it's because of the mistreatment
but when I'm and actually the studies
that I've seen are much higher than even
four times
um let's four times is bad enough right
it's it's tragic but actually there have
been studies no Swedish studies that
show it's 19 times 18 to 19 times more
likely but the number is the same both
free and post-op and here's my issue and
I tried to discuss this earlier
um American slaves I think we would both
agree were mistreated right yes
well they didn't have the same they
didn't have the same attempted suicide
rate Jews in the Holocaust didn't have a
four-time suicide rate not even close
Americans pre-civil rights what I'm
saying is people who have been
discriminated against and truly I think
we would both agree abused and
mistreated even if you go to gays for
example in the United States in the 80s
during the HIV epidemic right where they
were very stigmatized they didn't have
anywhere near this attempted suicide
rate and it exists both pre and post-op
and the reason that I bring it up is
because I think that you're I mean I
think you're a kind person I think
obviously respectful person what limited
time I've had with you I think it's
misframed for example where people think
if I say the solution is not
transitioning or changing the entire
societal structure to Limitless genders
it's not because my heart doesn't break
for these people it's because it doesn't
work it's not because of societal
mistreatment and transitioning doesn't
make it any better it may make it worse
I don't necessarily agree with that
um and I say this as a um because I am
I'm a queer person and I grew up in a
Bible Belt Texas I grew up in South
Texas I grew up with very conservative
family members very religious people and
so I've experienced a lot of a lot of
mistreatment and so I completely
understand I under I can see that aspect
of it because I have that Viewpoint
right whereas people perhaps like you um
may not and that was that was very
polarizing I apologize no no no no I I
understand and actually people from your
Viewpoint perhaps may not be able to see
it but I do know a lot of queer people
do have a lot more of those issues not
necessarily but it was because how they
were treated which is why again I don't
necessarily agree that it is because it
is of transitioning well what I'm saying
is for example and I would like to go
back to the term queer where you can
probably educate me because it means
different things to different people and
honestly I feel sometimes that I don't
get a handle on it oh absolutely because
I've had two queer people sit down and
they both argued about what it meant and
I'm like I'm just going to step out of
this one but I will say this uh you know
I was raised uh I am a Christian uh more
conservative but I was raised in
socialist Quebec in public schools
um where and also I was dual citizen but
I was raised from three to eighteen in
Canada and I will tell you this we
actually have something called The
League meaning language police and where
they would actually enforce I was forced
for example to go to all French schools
until the third grade where they thought
I was learning disabled and I speak
French but it's hard for me to learn
math and you know history in French oh
yeah um I have suffered from clinical
depression in my life to a very severe
degree
um so I can relate to it and I have
again because I was very much a fish out
of water I can relate to it in a way
that might surprise people even though
I'm a white male I was an
English-speaking half American
conservative male and a socialist
liberal province that forced me in
different schools and I think that
rather than someone saying it was
because of the mistreatment but
examining finally my issues that I could
control where I did suffer from
depression and ADHD that it helped me a
lot and I did have people who enabled it
at certain periods of time rather than
getting to the root cause what I'm
saying is when you look at them as
treatment of groups throughout history
they still don't have anywhere near the
attempted suicide rate of transgenders
including queer women in the Bible Belt
it's still not four times or 18 times so
there must be another variable there and
if we shut down the dialogue we may
never actually examine what that
variable is
um like I said again I don't 100 agree
with that especially um because I'm
viewing it from a youth standpoint of
younger of say people My Generation
because I know for a fact that our
generation is probably has the most
mental health issues that this country's
ever seen and it's because of
circumstances that have happened as we
have grown up let me ask you this would
you say are you Generation Z yes okay
would you say and I don't want to
mischaracterize this statistically I was
in this is true but would you say that
Generation Z is probably or arguably the
most open-minded generation as it
relates to these gender issues
absolutely okay so when you combine that
with the fact that your generation still
has more mental health issues and all
that have come before it
how do you juxtapose that and say it's
because of mistreatment it's the most
tolerant generation of all time and they
have more mental health issues and for
example men coming back from World War
II
um I think that's actually a great
question good job for that it's not a
God I'm genuinely curious
well I think it's an absolutely great
conversation
um so the reason that I believe that gen
Z does have the most mental health
issues is you have to realize that we
start what the very first year is 1998
so that means that what you have 1999
1980 or I think 2000 2001 the very first
people were in this generation were
three years into their lives was 9 11
which was arguably the worst terrorist
attack that has happened in the United
States and on American soil
um many gen Z they don't even remember
it yeah I feel really old when I talk
about it they're like absolutely I don't
remember I'm like oh boy I was born in
2003 so I wasn't even there for that I
wasn't even the concept that that's
playing but um yeah
absolutely but you do have to realize
that the world especially in America
changed very drastically after 2001. it
changed very drastically after there's
very much a and this is taught in
history classes there's very much a
difference between pre-911 and very much
a difference between post-911 and post
911 is seen as its own part of History
because a lot of things have changed
um nowadays kids in my generation aren't
allowed to go outside because they're
too worried about safety whereas
people it may ask how old you are is
that Ruth no 35 35. so I'm not a kind of
middle young Millennial yeah yeah
um my like my parents growing up were
just allowed to go outside and their
parents didn't care where they were
whereas my parents were like no you're
you're a girl you can't go outside by
yourself even if it isn't Suburbia
um we have to deal with a lot of because
the world is very much changing and in
some in a lot of places it's changed for
the worse and especially since we have a
lot of media that typically just Hummels
you with all these bad things that are
happening in the world that very much
changes a generation and if you are
constantly seeing that and you are
constantly exposed to life-changing
things dead bodies Wars terrorist
attacks
um it very much changes your perception
on life and it's very easy for people in
my generation to feel hopeless because
of that not because we're open-minded I
believe that our generation is so
open-minded because we see all the bad
things happening in the world because we
were like oh we can at least be
compassionate for one another that's the
very least we can do
I will say this uh I've changed my mind
on issues in the past I don't think
you've changed my mind on this issue but
yeah I didn't know but what you have
done is present a compelling argument
that I think should be included
um I've discussed this in the past that
we certainly do have let me put it this
way I don't think that this generate
Generation Z has it harder than 16 year
olds on the beaches of Normandy no of
course of course but I understand
I believe they had a sense of purpose
right that they were fighting an evil
not to see a regime whereas I do think
your point is well taken when you
combine this constant flow of
information and yes negativity with what
I do think is considering this kind of
like you said post 911 post post-war and
the global sense generation a lack of
purpose
um that it's a it's a chronic stressor
rather than an acute one yes um because
I can say that could be damaging you
have to remember that a lot of those
boys that were sent off in the war also
a lot of them typically lied on their
things to go off to war because that was
something they needed for their families
and stuff like that so some of them
wanted to go and they felt a sense of
purpose they wanted to serve their
country at what cost but they ended up
doing that yes so yes it's very much a
chronic stressor of constant things like
you have to like yeah we have now we
have
um Ukraine and Russia and we're seeing
about all over we've lived through that
I've lived through we've all lived
through a global pandemic but I was in
high school whenever that happened and I
was supposed to be graduating and we had
to wear masks we had the social distance
from each other and it was very hard to
have that social thing as it was for
everyone in the world we've had that
we've had all sorts of things that have
happened within our lifetime that are
these big Global events which is why I
don't think it's I don't think being
open-minded is inhibiting us at all no
and I wasn't saying because you're
you're two kind of separate issues
they're I think we both agree there are
more mental health issues with this
generation than previous generations but
what I am saying is that this generation
for example the transgender suicide
statistics don't really change
generationally so you would think that
transgenders from let's say Millennials
from Gen X you would think that the
rates would be higher there they're
every bit as high with Gen Z so I'm
saying separate from the suicide and
mental health issues at large the
treatment of them is certainly what
people would consider more tolerant with
Gen Z but the metrics haven't improved
and so I would say well okay maybe we
need to look to another variable there
is no demographic that has that same
attempted suicide rate there's only one
yeah yeah
um and I don't it's it's paranoid
schizophrenics it's the only place it
has a 40 over 40 percent attempted
suicide rate which is approximate with
transgender individuals
um which brings me kind of to another
point I think
I really do think it's a thoughtful
point that you made and I actually would
like to go do more research and actually
look at the before and after 9 11 mental
health issues I think it's an
interesting study
um but my question would now bring to if
we say
first off can I ask you a question how
many how many genders
are there if I say there I've actually
watched some of your stuff and I know
that I know you don't like this answer I
know you don't I'm so sorry but you
don't like my dancer I appreciate you
can probably understand this yes
like I said I have people in my life
that very much are like there are only
two genders and I'm just like
just like an infinite Spectrum I do
believe that you can identify how you
can identify with what you are and so if
you if you identify some of that's
non-binary I believe that you should be
allowed to do that and I believe that
you should be allowed to do that and
people should be respectful about it
um I do think that on the number of
genders I don't think there is a limited
number I think you can identify how you
want to identify typically
um people tend to identify as a
man-woman non-binary but even then I
don't like because non-binary is a
umbrella term right where it of course
covers all of these nuanced gender
identities but some people don't like
the term but then where do you draw a
line where do you draw a line for
example like I'm taking an extreme
example to make a point here I'm not
saying this is the norm but if someone
identifies as a feline you know this
happens a lot if someone a more common
issue is people identify as amputees
right this is an issue where matter
professionals are having people come in
asking them to remove a limb right if
you say it's infinite well then there is
no number on that happening do you
happen to know I would say if it's if
it's a hundred if it's a thousand if
it's any and it shouldn't be a medical
quandary as a nurse you know what I mean
it shouldn't be an ethical quandary but
now it is and I what I would say is look
we've had two genders and we understand
I think you seem intelligent enough to
know that I acknowledge the 0.01 who are
intersex and these are anomalies that's
not the same as the transgender I do
believe
um you said .01 it's point zero one as
far as I believe that um that was from a
study in uh 2002 and I believe the um
number now is about
seven percent which is about the same
number of redheads in the world so
that's like 17. I know let's say that
they brought up but then actually we had
a uh what's his name the journalist
scaramucci I can't remember his name
when I was at UTD try and bring it up
and in that own in that very study it
actually said the number is closer to
point point zero one
so even in that that study uh they had
misread the statistics
um it's certainly not over one percent
but we can disagree it's still very very
low uh I would maintain it's not only a
20 2002 study there have been studies
reiterated since then but even then what
I would say is this let's say let's say
it's one percent to a sake of argument
in nursing school for example it's a
certainly a higher percentage of people
who are born without a limp than people
who are intersex yes but you're still
taught in Biology class there are
exceptions human beings generally have
two arms two legs for example you use
hearing aids right but in biology I'm
sure nursing school they probably teach
you Basics about the eardrums right
basically about the ear canal and say
and there are exceptions to these rules
but this is generally the human anatomy
we are now asking people to restructure
how we teach biology based on a very
small percentage and if we say well no
two genders is wrong if you tear down
that what I would say is a fundamental
structure in society I think you need to
replace it with something equally
concrete not it could change at any time
I um you say that we're teaching
we're not being taught that in my as far
as sex yes as far as sex we're not being
taught sure it is mentioned that there
are intersex people and I don't think
that we should look over those people
because
and they present their own set of
medical things that you have to look
into because nowadays you hear a lot of
stories about intersex people who have
had organs removed as children without
their consent and that's a very hard
thing and so you can't completely
Overlook no I don't overlook but I'm
saying how we teach it how we teach it
is that we have male and female like you
said they teach too and they teach there
are some exceptions but they don't teach
that they're Limitless sexes
because sex and gender again are two
things and we're taught but that's not
where we are right because when you have
people again if this would be I would
agree with you at least the premise if
for example consistently
male and female were used to describe
sex and man and woman were used to
describe gender but they're not they're
not even in a legal sense when you're
talking about proper identification
they're not when you talk about this
Administration referring to Rachel
Levine as a female they're not even used
that way when you say male to female
transgender right they're talking about
we both agree you can't change your
biological sex but it's MTF FTM male to
female not mtw not man to woman there's
no consistency and the issue is when you
combine that with the compulsion of
language for example in Canada or in
certain areas speech laws if we say
there are Limitless genders then there
are Limitless pronouns
um which I um yeah I would just go sorry
no you're okay and um I'm actually
learning Spanish because I I'm I'm
biracial my my dad or my mom is white my
dad is a Mexican and so I'm currently in
the process of learning Spanish which is
also a romance language gendered nouns
right masculine yeah it's very gendered
um well one of the few languages that
don't happen actually in English it's
very common and yeah and um again very
much like you said there is
such language and what is correct and
what's Incorrect and this institution is
very much like gender-neutral pronouns
aren't to be used but people within
those communities have very much
reclaimed that right
especially those in Latin America or
like people you see here in the United
States which is why you have terms such
as latinx or you have different terms so
that is slowly beginning to change again
with the times I would argue it's
actually gender identity
it's not as far as latinx because the
vast majority of Hispanic people both in
South America Latin America and Hispanic
Americans it's less than two percent who
like the term latinx and it's more than
50 who hate it across all generations I
know I know that that's I don't think
that's correct at all it's statistically
it is though again
um I think it has to do with Generations
I know a lot of young people who very
much prefer that term
um over older people but then again
those older in the United States not in
Latin America the older people that I
know again are the same kind of people
that would agree with
[Music]
with older people I'm talking about
younger people in Latin America or even
younger people in Mexico they do not
like it's it's exclusively respectfully
largely white Americans who use that
term not even young Hispanics but let me
ask you this and I would like to go back
to the the sort of the queer topic but
um they use that term the queer talk but
determine how it identifies because it
does tie into this I have asked this
question here today and understand this
is not a gotcha it is a serious concern
for someone like me as a father
the idea now and then when I brought
this up in 2018 people said that's
absurd you're you're trying to be
incendiary the idea of transitioning
puberty blockers for children you're a
nurse as well you're going to be a nurse
apologies
um can we find Common Ground here I've
spoken with some people today one person
who is pro-lgbt agreed with me one
person did not believe that children
should be allowed to make those
decisions to transition
if we can't find common ground that
children are in no position to make
permanent decisions regarding their
biological makeup and blocking puberty
or undergoing gender reassignment
surgery
as civil as this discourse has been I
don't think there's any help to find
common ground where do you line up on
children transition I personally just
kind of I think
different from what is being asked
advertised right here well no let me
explain to you why I think it's uh I
think it's a very nuanced topic um I
believe that it should be up to the
child and the parents
um up to doctors up to I don't think it
should be made illegal because that just
there are very
how do I phrase this sorry I'm trying to
get my I will say I completely believe
it should be illegal for the same reason
that 10 year olds can't consent to sex
okay if a child can't consent to sex why
can they consent to a sexual
reassignment surgery that will affect
their sex life forever okay I don't know
how I don't know why we would leave that
decision to a child children are not
capable their brains are not developed
and capable of making a permanent
life-altering decision like that and
understanding the consequences could we
not agree at waiting until they're 18 to
make that decision rather than rushing
them along as children I do think that
um so again you use puberty blockers
which is if you want to use for children
yes I'm not sure that the rates of
gender reassignment surgery in trans
children it's very high for the fact
that most doctors are not going to want
to do that as it is seen that most
doctors aren't wanting to do gender
reassignment surgeries as you mentioned
earlier with John Hopkins saying I don't
know about that so that rate is not that
high well it's not high yet right that's
the reverse Nirvana effect well since it
hasn't happened yet but if we open it up
for example there are lawsuits against
Johns Hopkins right now right just
because we haven't done it yet it's
because there have been archaic fossils
like me who say we can't allow children
to transition question if we allow it
you're going to have a much much higher
number right we do have to make a
decision
if you use it
you use this if we don't let people do
if we let people do this the numbers are
going to get higher typically in a lot
of
um that's not how it happened with
children it does let me give you and
this is something that is and this is
something that's important again
with children for example children who
identify as transgender
um if you do nothing if you do nothing
if you don't intervene the lowest number
you will find from a larger study is
about 85 percent there are numbers as
high as 97 percent of them grow out of
it completely they were a tomboy some of
them were gay right they weren't
transgender the moment you intervene and
you administer puberty blockers or
hormone replacement therapy the number
goes down to zero
and by the way once that number go down
to zero that means that 100 of those
children are now on the 42 attempted
suicide demographic
so going to be in that same Geographic
because they grow out of it
statistically they grow out of it and it
was a phase it was a phase for most of
these kids it's 85 to 97 where they grow
out of it just like kids grow out of a
lot of things right I don't think that's
I don't necessarily agree with that
because
um especially in again
um may I ask are you in the lgbtq plus
infinity no no no I am not lgbtq but I'm
talking about the fact is most of these
children some of them do do say you know
what it turns out I have a friend
actually on the show I said I thought I
was trans turned out I was just a gay
man so some of those 90 something
percent end up being gay or lesbian
but they all grow out of claiming to be
transgender the vast majority only when
you intervene and you change the
neurochemistry which we know if you
administer puberty blockers or estrogen
or testosterone right that changes the
way the brain develops now you've
actually changed their course they grow
out of it and no longer identify as
trans
if there's no Intervention when they are
children but who's to say that they
can't de-transit
Ive that argument is brought up a lot a
lot of um it's actually they've
discovered that it's kind of being blown
up kind of out of proportion the number
of people that um like it's being the
media very much blows up uh the number
of people that are de-transitioning
whenever it's not as big as many people
think well they're dismissed and they're
marginalized but if that number is
that's so significant
um in the argument that of people
transitioning is like oh what if they
want to de-transition why can't you say
the same thing for these children again
because it's a Hippocratic Oath first Do
no harm and puberty blockers and
intervention hormonally in a child
absolutely does more harm than doing
nothing we would have to grant that
maybe the harm somebody would argue the
harm is minimal but no one is arguing
that puberty blockers do not come with
the risk of sterility a high risk when
compared to other drugs no one is
arguing that puberty blockers often
stunt growth permanently of course we
acknowledge that no one is arguing that
administering testosterone to a teenage
girl will change her body her bone
mineral density which to an unnatural
degree no one is arguing that or that
estrogen for a young boy will result in
in developmental abnormalities in their
cerebral cortex their frontal lobe no
one is arguing that those aren't so in
other words medical Intervention when
they are a child
absolutely does more harm than waiting
until they're an adult I don't think
that's Up For Debate as to what degree
of harm but it does more harm than doing
nothing
would be my position and again I'm I
guess I'm looking at this at a very
different Viewpoint because I'm wanting
to be a nursing student and
um you were fundamentally taught that
not only is the physical body something
that you treat
mental the mind is also something those
are two very interconnected things sure
in order for a person to be healthy not
only do they have to have a healthy body
but they also have to have a healthy
mind so with that I'm looking at it at
the sense of if these children again
because me and you look at that suicide
rate very differently which is where I
think we're coming at kind of like this
well I think we both have concern though
which I appreciate yeah just different
different solutions different forms no
that's fine don't worry about different
forms of concern I think because again I
think that I'm not 100 sure that
um children should have gender
reassignment surgery just because it's a
very invasive procedure and I don't
believe that they should be able to have
that until they're 18. so that's just my
opinion if
um if this child is deemed if it's
deemed medically medically necessary to
have it for like say their mental health
then because gender dysphoria is a very
it's a very awful thing it doesn't
improve their mental health it doesn't
that's the point the problem is if in
other words if you were to be able to
say if we intervene this is medically
necessary for their mental health but
the Sue is the attempted suicide rate
stays the same irrefutably it does not
improve post-op
you've now performed by what you've
described and I agree with you a very
medically invasive whether it's surgery
or puberty blockers and you've not
improved the mental health as a matter
of fact you could make it worse once
that child grows up and realize oh my
God I would have grown out of it but
they never were given the chance to I
think but again you can medically
detransition which is not everybody can
with puberty blockers it's not it's not
true they're puberty blockers they they
come with some ramifications that can be
permanent for many people we can both
not everyone but a significant
percentage yes I do I do know this
because I've seen many videos and case
studies
of this the transitioning where they do
have some of those things and yes
they're you there's some things that you
can't change right which is why I say if
you're so worried about
them growing out of it don't let them
surgically transition until they're 18.
again but that I think
discussions some of them do not revert
back to a normal puberty phase a good
portion of them the idea that in other
words we say well if you use Purity
blockers it's reversible well it's not
always reversible you know what is
reversible going through puberty and
where you're an adult capable of making
decisions deciding to transition yeah I
like I said I do think we're hitting our
wall okay which is but but that's
completely I think we have more common
ground than maybe I understand where
you're coming from yeah and I really do
appreciate how respectful you've been
I'm sorry that these Hooligans have been
yelling um let me ask you you said queer
yes sir so to a silly CIS straight white
male like myself uh
what is that when you say queer what do
you mean because some people mean it in
different ways yes sir so
um you don't mind me calling you sir
right no you can call me whatever you
want okay because I know some people I
grew up very much where manners are very
much a thing and I know some other
places it's like if you're called Sir
like you're calling them old that's rude
no no you can call me whatever you want
you've been very respectful and I really
have enjoyed our conversation okay me
too
um so I very much
um I completely forgot the question okay
queer I was like I was like I'm so sorry
um so yes uh historically queer has been
used to mean the word strange on that's
very much a thing
um I still use it when watching it used
to be a term like unboxing they say the
guy gets you know like clipped they
would say oh it's put them on queer
Street and that just means that he's
he's out of it so it wasn't even it
wasn't a sexual term it was just like
queer Street meant you're close to
getting knocked out so
um
but uh queer ended up being used as a
derogatory term towards lgbtq plus
people which is because of course words
of course have their trajectory in
history their usage it happens a lot
with a bunch of different terms
um but now
um they a lot of lgbtq plus people
that's what the Q is in lgbtq right it's
queer well not always some people say
it's questioning some people do say it's
questioning I say it as queer it's just
it's very
um
but the queue is used queer is very much
especially in the community it's used as
an umbrella term
just to Encompass people
that perhaps wouldn't want to identify
as anything else don't prefer other
labels
um so you're you're not lesbian does
queer mean that you're you're not
bisexual but you're not a lesbian does
fear mean what does queer mean then
because again bisexual lesbian I
understand I think again I think very
much like the whole gender identity
thing I think it's just kind of how you
personally identify I use queer just
because I don't feel as though anything
else truly income encompasses me as a
person
um do you mean you can always tell me if
they're too invasive do you mean as far
as your orientation or your gender or
both
um typically my orientation okay
um so are you trying both men and women
uh yes I have okay so how is that
so again it would seem to me that that
would be that would fit under bisexual
[Applause]
no that's fine okay
so typically people that are bisexual
experience
um and again you probably are going to
hear this and be like I don't know
which is why I think it's wonderful to
explain a little bit more sure
especially if people I'm genuinely
curious because I've had different
people give me different definitions of
of queer yeah yes so
um like you said queer is very much to
juice as an umbrella term for a lot of
different people and I like that label a
lot just because it's not Ultra specific
because again it's just an umbrella term
and it's not like I'm picking and
choosing at things just because I'm not
a huge fan of labels because I've
realized that a lot of people
um put you in a box with labels right if
you identify sometimes as something they
just view you very much with stereotypes
and I'm not a huge fan of that and
um but bisexual people are those that
are attracted to
uh and I know you're gonna hear this and
you're gonna be like what do you mean or
more uh typically bisexual people
um the definition within the community
and which is more widely accepted is uh
those that are attracted to two or more
genders right
um so I thought it just meant because
bye would mean yeah which is why I was
like you'll probably hear this if you're
like what in the world
um because it would make sense to me if
bisexual means you're attracted to male
female yes and queer means two or more
that would make more sense but I have
heard this where bisexual doesn't mean
too I'm like well I have to buy yeah
that is very hard for uh people to grasp
but it's very much two genders are very
much two or more genders and
um which is again that whole concept
goes with our there are only two genders
because especially underneath like
things such as bisexual or even labels
such as pansexual which is not often
talk of talked about yeah it is as I
understand it
pansexual means that you can be queer in
orientation and gender fluid yourself as
well pansexual means that you are um oh
don't worry about it no problem
um uh pansexual means that you are
attracted to people regardless of gender
this is how I've always heard it and I
have people that identify as that and
that's very much how they feel how is
that different from queer from queer
like I said queer is very much an
umbrella term so it encompasses so
pansexual could go under queer yes okay
very much so yes okay so the wiser LGBT
sometimes they include a p even after
the queue uh not typically it's
typically it is
lqi
plus so I've seen lgbtq AIP at a
feminist film festival and I've seen
even aaip but I have quite commonly seen
AIP I've never seen it with the Pete but
so P should go under Q I'm not saying it
should go under Cube because it can if
that person identifies with that but Q
couldn't go under p
like I said Q can be used as an umbrella
term or it can be used as its own
separate thing
yeah well look here's the thing uh I'm
not going to agree with the changing of
the acronym as long as as long as unlike
the Canadian government you don't compel
me to use that language yeah like
whatever you say you are I'll say okay
fine but I'm probably not going to keep
adding lgbtqai peer allow someone to say
this is why typically I just say lgbtq
you okay it's very simple
it seems like but then at that point
then it just seems like a q is the
umbrella term just say Q because LGBT
could all fit under Q well I mean again
people
um very much identify with those labels
um there were previous labels that I
used that I stopped using because I
didn't feel comfortable because a lot of
especially with um lesbian the term
lesbian that has a historical history
behind it and I don't want to not
necessarily offend but I just don't feel
comfortable using it plaid shirts and
Buzz Cuts no that's very much a
stereotype that's what I'm saying it
became a stereotype and then I noticed a
lot of women are like well I'm a lesbian
but I'm not I'm a lesbian where I work
with it was like I'm a lesbian but I'm
not that kind of lesbian so she says Q
even though she's not bisexual She's a
Lesbian but she will say I just I'm not
a stereotypical I mean lesbians can come
in all shapes and sizes all form so you
don't have to be but this lesbian is
aggravated by it okay and she even she
drives a Subaru and she goes by the way
it's just it's a coincidence I got a
good deal it's not because I'm a lesbian
and actually we have a lot of fun with
it where she goes I get the stereotype
um and I think it always look like I
said I'm going to disagree with the
acronym the language the fundamental
changing of it we're going
[Music]
that people can do is we leave this
conversation understand we come from
different perspectives absolutely but I
think yours comes from empathy and even
if people might think mine is not it
comes from wanting different solutions
and empathy
conservatives there's this this uh this
misinterpretation that if they disagree
it must be intolerant or hateful it's
not it's just yeah it's rooted in not
only a very different world view but I
would argue like there is a lot of data
to reflect
we're going down a very dangerous path
with like children transitioning and
unfortunately the senior today people
get shouted down
um and that's something we we have to
get past even if
even if I was Baby Hitler which I'm not
I'm just saying that you know we need to
be able to have these conversations uh
and I really appreciate you and you know
what I think I think a big part of that
is probably because
kind of like me you know I was raised as
a Conservative Christian in a very very
left right uh very left and not only
that I want to I'm not Catholic I went
to public schools which were all
Catholic when I was being raised so I
was forced to understand their
perspective
and sort of Forge in the fire and the
same thing with you on the flip side if
you were raising the Bible Belt
Christian conservatives you've probably
had to argue your position oh absolutely
which is why
earlier you mentioned the conservatives
are seen as intolerant
um a majority of my life I've seen
conservatives as
I know oh it was a spider oh geez I'm
very intolerant of spiders I don't like
them it just fully crawled on me oh God
that's fine that's okay no it's not fun
I'm gonna kill it after find it I will
but
um I I grew up seeing conservatives as
very intolerant and it was just because
the conservative people that I had in my
life were very intolerant in the sense
of they're not open the conversation
yeah which is why
um today whenever I see people walking
by and just being like Oh but I'm just
like you either one should ignore it
it's if ignore it or I adding fuel to
the fire isn't that great it's it's just
there's no if you can't have a
conversation about it nothing's going to
get done but you're a classical liberal
in that sense because even though we
disagree you can sit down express your
point of view and some people on the
left view that in and of itself as
adding fuel to the fire yeah and I would
argue adding fuel to the fire is simply
trying to eliminate voices from the
conversation by the way whether it's
being completely polarizing and just
being like you suck right yeah well I
don't think that's taking place here
yeah so I'm sorry your name again was uh
Gabriella Gabriella Gabrielle Gabriella
I will remember I'm horrible with names
I'll never forget your face
Gabrielle thank you so much I really do
appreciate it this was wonderful thank
you I wish that all of our Congress all
my conversations could be like this but
unfortunately they're not yeah and again
we don't 100 agree on and everything but
it's still it's cool no yeah and I would
I would defend your right to say
anything you have to say to the death uh
regardless of how much I disagree with
him so thank you Gabriella and I know
this has been a long time do you have
big following plans
my roommate left for the day I think I
have to take care of her dog don't watch
barbarian barbarian my dad was talking
about it he said it sucks gross isn't it
if you're gonna watch it I want to spoil
it for you I don't know it's really
gross it's like gory
no gross like okay I'll put this happens
early in the film okay you can go ahead
and tell me the worst thing is so it's
this it's uh it's this woman who's in
she's like a victim of a guy who would
lock up had a butt inbred in the
basement and had a bunch of children and
she's obsessed with locking people and
trying to make them her big so she
forcefully breastfeeds them and she's in
red picture of The Hills Have Eyes and
she has a stringy black hair and I was
eating Ramen oh there's a stringy black
boob hair
so I just I feel the need to warn
everyone if they're gonna see no it's
really gross it's okay I've watched I I
love horror movies so I've watched like
most of the saws I can only sit through
like three before I'm like I gotta yeah
no it's not a bad movie but I just warn
you
I just saw the trailer I had no idea
what I was in for so I figured Halloween
if you're going up to your room you
might have that on the docket just be
warm don't eat ramen
that's me I'm nightly Ramen I don't know
after don't watch it while eating rum
all right thank you so much Gabrielle
thank you very much of course I
appreciate it you too hey look at that
even Joe Lewis is happier that's just
because you stole the whole pie
from the studio he did do that look
Gabriella and I agree on pretty much
nothing and we were able to have a
productive civil conversation uh one of
my favorite conversations ever let me
know which future installments you'd
like to see and change but he's pushing
me off my chair okay thank you which
future installments you would most like
to see uh for Change My Mind comment
below hit the like button if you want to
see more of these change my Minds uh
coming on down the pike as well as oh my
gosh she's getting into other food uh
click one of these other videos that's
playing in the Box no